вина на сході України і забрала у
валентини ці річки кухонних у людини
сидить і ну за місяць із дологи були
людина
манана раді всім вони слуги хлопчики та
так вже кого
якщо одразу 2 трагедій джинси давалося
обидва на частку в тася ви знаєте
селенових біля вані це вранці вони ще два
дітей павла вид паршивим шлюп у нас
пильного вузла sll сина бог дано нині
пологи ножові в орендованій квартирі у
міс тачку буханців вершині валентино а
тримай невеликий у зарплат не експер убитий
накладного глядачі у мерії
2 7 місяців тому петля загинали батька
син богдан пуджа патри молодий ще й пенсі
вигляд держави так грушею катастрофічно
нього старша держава пружини за померлих
за дав сміховий ну пенсію
вбирають шиза дві з половиною тисячі я
чоловікові прогодувати дитину
я дякую де всередині я може заплатити та
всього лише підсумку valentini дуго лося ви
витрат це бан від шансу і не рви
на яка покарай вибуття з держави
соціальну допомогу пологи на так вже сп
одягається вранці це вид держави
однокімнатну квартиру як у волонтерів
ж пишу кола сама гаю на ces бюджету
виділили
а починав на які комітеті в ліжко не
може ви означає якщо і крима і but i do
гувер купили продаж вже в закладі
чітко їх інструктивне підписано та
далі проходять крилаті далі
доводиться обертів проходьте добувати
всі самі стук від аварій кричать і шуя не
баран ту допомогою менеджер про бездротових
фірм до його вдова андрея стоянка аллена
за пиво руку так вона змогла 2 тис
вимова david & rich не данте
ґрунтована державою допомога
але є за силу зазирнувши на фронті
по мер через скільки днів після
демобілізації
адже серце бога нападу за виставку
малика риф хвороба завела собі годину
служби у так їхній випад koch виплати та
пили видно віско підлозі передачі не
алла механізм законодавства прописано
снів що ти не читаю укушу koch вигляд
побачи аллена обійшла вже всі відомства
та служби
мені на вас чайна пригла такий
інформативні служби вудману
розгорнути і сім і дтп може
проконсультувати і праворуч ти в
потрібної інстанції юрист з пилкою в і
тараненко його studyblue випад до вимиюся
справа навіть часто свої про бульбашки для
виправлення тиче кастою законів roussos
допомогу рубіном загинах вони вже
направив і до парламенту тут can статуї
вчений ритку простіше для нехай допоможуть навіть
бюджету виділяється а також на місцях
найкращому на може розпорядитися а для
тих же соціальних службового джерела
інформації ща даного дещо на
dosage обсяг надавала equis тренінги
кислої акції до нових film a би
не був ваш кахудо психологічно валентино
об'їдалася одна scheme вдовам та он їду
допомагають 1 днів
young хибно бо сторонні люди з
україни це за кордон у тих, хто їх чекав
не постів з будьте на цілувати кофти
датчику 6 лава стрічки ще з допомоги або
2 ста в бучі 9 різанини програма на пит
ринку рубін за гиблих а ви так і
збувається велетня у всіх місцях на
адже на київщині на її кулю ситуація
заданому гру травневих організацій
севський міс цілості